so this week's inner Europe has been
going on and during Cinna Europe they
released a clip of Avengers for security
for the showing was super tight everyone
that attended had their phones and
cameras taken away from them so
unfortunately I don't think that we're
gonna receive any sort of leaked version
online anywhere but fan descriptions
have been coming out and they have
confirmed a few theories and rumours
that have been going around about
Avengers four before we dive into it be
sure to subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on avengers' for one of the
fans has taken to the Internet already
and stated what he or she saw here's
what this person had to say about the
footage that was shown Avengers four
footage showed ant-man talking with Tony
Stark about a new piece of technology
that will allow them to go to multiple
realities and collect the Infinity
stones so it's confirmed Avengers 4 will
take us into multiple different
realities another thing that is
confirmed is that Ant Man obviously
plays a huge role in Avengers 4 and
obviously the technology they're
referring to is the quantum realm
technology that doctor Hank Pym creates
so this confirms that the leaked photos
that we've seen with ant-man the Hulk
Captain America and Iron Man are in fact
them traveling throughout time in
different realities and not using barf
technology so they're going throughout
different realities to gather Infinity
stones so they can use them in their own
Infinity Gauntlet this is right on track
with a plot late that was released not
too long ago that stated they were going
to multiple realities so it seems like
that ended up being true and the
question is if that's true is it also
true that Iron Man is going to forge his
own Infinity Gauntlet the way I see it
is that there are two main ways for the
Avengers to get their hands on a
different Infinity Gauntlet one way
which makes a lot of sense is that they
can simply go to another reality go to
neduvaali and have King treet forge them
an Infinity Gauntlet this is likely
because he created infinity gallon for
Thanos and infinity war so it wouldn't
be too hard to go to a different reality
and
to them what they're trying to do and
tell him that they need the Infinity
Gauntlet because Thanos is going to come
and kill all of those who are on Neda
Blair and not to mention half of the
universe will be knocked out as well the
second one is the Iron Man theory that
Tony Stark himself will forge his own
Infinity Gauntlet it's very possible
Tony is a genius and a master engineer
not to mention he's an expert at
building and designing weapons which if
you think about it that's all the
Infinity Gauntlet really is it's a
weapon designed to contain all of the
power of the Infinity stones and then
use them I mean the guy actually created
a new element and that element generates
power similar to the tesseract and the
tesseract is a space stone so it's
actually very believable that Tony Stark
could create an Infinity Gauntlet to
hold all the power of the Infinity
stones this is what I would personally
love to see I think along with a lot of
other fans because I'd love to see him
willed the Infinity got went like he
does in the comics and not to mention
how epic would it be to see Iron Man
with his Infinity Gauntlet go
head-to-head with Thanos and his
Infinity Gauntlet so I hope we see it
but what do you all think do you think
Tony is gonna create his own Infinity
Gauntlet or do you think the Avengers
will just go to King III let me know
your thoughts hopes and dreams in the
comments below hit that like button and
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on avengers' for Marvel DC and all
things superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]